Hello, hello, hello!
My boo!
Hi everybody, welcome back!
Hello!
Ah!
Minkiri.
That's me.
Hi everybody, welcome in.
Come here, help me!
Hi!
You made me on your Tomodachi Island!
I cannot believe!
It's crazy how uncensored this game is.
Today I decide whether I ever want to be sponsored by...
John Nintendo.
Prandenne is here.
Thank you so much for the 50 ki-tра.
Thank you!
What the heck!
Oh my goodness!
Thank you for another 50!
What the...
Thank you!
Welcome to Yaoi Island.
Weewee Wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee.
Wee wee wee.
Wee.
I put it in the pinned comment, but in case you're watching
the VOD or you can't see the comments for whatever reason,
today might be a little bit shorter because I...
I... I'm still recovering.
My cough is a little worse than it was yesterday.
I didn't get to sleep much.
And also, I streamed for a long time yesterday.
So maybe I pushed it just a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Maybe.
Maybe I did.
But that's okay.
We're balancing it.
Excited to see what you'll make.
I...
I've been thinking because I'm like I could make me and I
heard okay I heard a couple things um when I heard that you
can make up to three three me is in the demo but then I hear
that the demo is if you make the third me then you um then
the demo ends Payton, don't welcome back.
And the amount of Minky is a good amount.
Thank you, K-1.
Oh my gosh, Brides Up!
Please, your wallet.
I'm legitimately concerned, but thank you so much.
It ends after you give them clothes.
Oh!
Don't click on the trouble after making the third mean.
Okay, I have avoided watching other people play.
Obviously, like, the occasional clip here and there has
popped up into my timeline.
I cannot resist.
I am weak.
I am weak and I watch.
Oh, she can't possibly be this medicated!
Everything I've seen in the promotional material suggests
that this game was made for you specifically.
Let's go!
I am quite medicated!
I just took three pills.
But those are the rest of my pills for today.
Pills?
Where are my pills?
I don't need these.
Tomorrow I only have four pills.
Yippee!
Yay!
Pills here.
Thanks.
Thanks for reminding me I need to take my medicine.
Take your meds.
If you need to.
But, um...
crunch what are we crunching uh but yeah uh oh my gosh my
throat is like so flummy today i think also maybe i've been
coughing more because boy howdy is it allergy season baby
though it's the springtime has sprung time it is starting to
come out so i'm uh i think everyone will be feeling it a
little bit more.
I'm dying of hay fever over here.
No!
I love me too when Ivo's like you!
I can't wait to see the drama you caused on the island
stranded in the middle of nowhere.
It's gonna be peak.
It's real.
Saku!
I'll come back!
My allergies are destroying me.
Yeah, hopefully everybody!
Actually, oh my gosh.
When I...
You know how sometimes people are like this place is living
in 2070 or whatever.
But actually, Japan had this thing called, like, Aller
Screen.
Uh, hold on.
Let me double check the brand.
And it was a spray.
I don't know if the brand is pronounced Ihadah or Ihadah.
But it's I-H-A-D-A, Aller Screen Spray.
And it, like, I didn't pronounce it.
personally use it but some friends used it while in Japan
and they were like oh my gosh my hay fever is like like my
nose is not running anymore
so you just spray it on your face it's like water and you
spray it you kind of like spray it on your clothes too I
guess why not you had I don't know I had a you had a we had
a I don't know but yeah it's just kind of crazy I was like
what the heck how how I don't know I don't know if you could
find it somehow somewhere being sold but apparently it works
it's kind of crazy yeah magic spray that's what I kept
calling I was dang this stuff is amazing happy me thank you
i had an allergy now i don't maybe that's i had a i had an
allergy and now i don't thanks to the spray next day thank
you for giving us your time but i was thinking so much for
those thank you thank you
but i was thinking what do i want to do for do for my
island.
I was like, I can make me, I can make Snake.
You know, I can make us fall in love and then have Ocelot
steal Snake away from me at my wedding.
And then I cry a single tear because I know that they were
fated to be.
But that seems a little boring, maybe.
My favorite part of this game is when they said, really is
our tomodachi life too we are living the dream that enrolled
credits yeah they were they were looking into the sunset and
they said we're living the dream pony boy fade to black 80s
80s rock anthem play can't you do densetsu i thought about
that too but i kind of want something a little more cursed
you know what i mean I want something a little bit maybe
more...
Thank you.
It's strange.
Wait!
Callback!
Oh, it says that's from seven minutes ago.
Oh no, you sent it twice!
I'm sorry!
Why did that just come through?
I guess all the...
the...
memberships.
They delay the notification.
Thank you!
This is just the demo, so whenever we get to the actual
game, you know, we can make more people, obviously.
We can make whoever.
And everything.
We can make whatever.
But for the demo, I think I'm going to make Snake.
And I think I'm going to make Gengar.
That is my plan.
Thank you, thanks for the five, Gengar.
Thank you.
Irish welcome back thank ass welcome back snake ex-gengar
will they fall in love but I guess I need to make a third me
too huh by playing this demo you can get a sense of what the
retail version of Tomodachi life living the dream is like
hamburger me a classic of mine what about a hot dog And
players who complete the demo Will receive a hamster costume
Costume color cannot be selected Costume also available in
retail version I thought it was exclusive
I'm gonna live my best ham ham life Cousy, cousy, cousy,
cousy We hope you will enjoy the full demo.
By the way, any progress you make in the demo version can be
carried over to the retail version along with your saved
data.
Now, thank you!
Thank you, thank you for the thank you, dude!
Yeah, that's right.
Do the date and time look right to you?
Yes.
Other.
North America.
Proceed.
Dollars Proceed Region dog Because you guys are so stupid As
if I haven't always been like I'm on the East Coast
Power couple snake PTSD dreams Gengar eats them So true Yeah
you guys know I'm in America You filthy American dog Okay
Could have been South America.
Hmm, see?
East Gorsd!
You found a tiny island in the middle of the sea.
What will you do with the place and its residence?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
there's basketballs in the ocean.
Oh, oh, there aren't any residents.
Well, we can do something about that.
Let's invite some folks to live here.
It's just the place for me characters.
We'll call them mees for short.
They can look like real people.
Even people you know.
And you get to create them.
The power is scary.
Not sure what sort of me's to create there are no rules you
can add any me's that you dream up
As you add me is you can watch them live out their lives
they'll chat and play and even argue it's like an alternate
reality freaky Oh my gosh, she's so anime What have you
sprinkled in a fictional character or a celebrity a best
friend or oh Someone you admire.
Let your imagination fly.
Don't worry.
Don't worry you playing this game.
You can't get her.
But in the alternate reality, Tomodachi life, she's all
yours, baby.
Tomodachi life allows you to live your fantasies.
Today, I wanted to...
Marry a plate of spaghetti.
And in Tomodachi life, it's possible.
I can marry spaghetti.
I got...
I tried a new thing of pasta today.
You know when you're like...
Man, I'm gonna try something new.
And then I got it and it was so...
Disappointing!
It's possible.
Anything is possible.
I was told that I can't marry spaghetti because spaghetti is
a food.
And I said, that didn't stop that guy from marrying Hatsune
Miku.
And I was told, that is Miku, not spaghetti.
stop me who is to stop me someone married the Eiffel Tower
right I don't know actually wait he divorced her love is
dead no no he didn't why would he do that why would you
divorce Hatsune Miku he
didn't she cheated on him That's not true.
He married Teto instead.
Oh my god, the service that hosted the AI ended.
Is spaghetti chan returning?
Who's that?
When your Oshi wants to marry noodles, but the hidden
vegetables always interfere from the shadows.
I don't mind the vegetables.
I'll put a veggie in my spaghetti.
Let me put a veggie in you, girl.
That's what I would say to her.
My spaghetti.
But I'm married.
My dream is to be rejected by my Oshi in this game.
I wonder what kind of dramatic rejection it would be.
I'm gonna let my imagination fly.
Got a few ideas already?
Well, hang on to them for just a moment.
While we give the island a name.
It changes later if you want.
Oh, good.
I have no idea.
I didn't know anything goes.
What's that do?
Anything goes, island.
I thought.
Never mind.
Wait, add text.
The name of my island is...
It's not what vegetables are for, Minto.
It'd be lots of nutrients.
How long can I make it?
My petition for a shadow...
Oh, it seems pretty long, okay.
Oh wait, no, I don't think so.
Freak Island.
I think Outer Heaven is pretty good.
Zanzibar Land.
Shadow Moses.
Hmm.
Allysh, thank you so much for the vibe!
Well, their snake will be there.
I feel like I've seen, like, some crazy me's being made.
And I just don't have the creative ability.
Hmm.
I didn't think about this.
I thought about who to make, and I didn't think about what
to name my island.
I completely forgot.
I didn't think about it.
But we can change it, which is nice.
Uh...
Hmm.
Hmm...
I am...
Why is this so difficult?
Sorry, my brain is so foggy today.
It's tough to decide.
I know, right?
Shadow Akiba.
You guys are coming up with such serious things.
I want to be like...
I wonder if it will fit.
Bucket of Frogs.
Bucket of Frogs Island.
Did that sound right?
You can press lips to listen again or to correct the
pronunciation.
Bucket of Frogs Island.
This is where you can enter the proper pronunciation.
For example, if you want the word red to be pronounced like
the color red and not like a reed and a marsh, you would
want to spell it red here.
Oh, the text you enter will be used as is.
This pronunciation will only be used.
Oh, how do I say it?
What if I do this?
Yeah!
I wonder what it'll say.
Yay.
Get strong, your own.
way to him inside her own island.
The S is silent.
Work's been slow, so I hope I can watch your streams during
work.
Oh, good luck with work.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's the frogs.
I mean, it said calmly.
I'll just change it later.
Bucket of frogs.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, that's not how you pronounce it.
Please, everybody, respect how the pronunciation is.
This island will develop as you add residents.
Having six or more residents will help the mees live happy,
fun lives.
You can add up to three residents in the demo version.
Are you ready?
Got a meme in mine?
Let's invent, invite your very first resident to...
Yeah.
Welcome back.
Yay!
It's telling me already to get some help!
Oh, if you've never created a me before, you can select get
help.
If you'd like to take a hands-on approach, give from scratch
a try.
You can always edit any me that you create no matter which
creation option you select here.
Okay, from scratch.
Gengar!
I'm looking at him right now, I have a little plush above
me.
To edit different aspects of your me's face, browse these
categories.
I'm so excited because I did not play...
Oh, each feature can be adjusted.
Yeah, yeah, this is all not new.
That's everything for now.
Feel free to start creating.
Um, I didn't get to play the, uh, what's it called?
pronunciation yay welcome back wow get stronger yeah me
topia so i'm excited to see if it's any you know all right
my my guy is purple actually i feel like i've always liked a
light i think the shiny gangar is like my preferred Gengar
because he almost looks the exact same but he's a lighter
purple it's kind of a really bad shiny color because yeah
and look they give us like spiky hairs and everything so
it's easy
oh it's coming out so well
William Afton.
That's too Brock.
There's so many different hairstyles.
This one's pretty good too.
There's so many new hairstyles.
This one's so cute.
Oh, it's so cute.
Now I'm just looking at him.
Grape.
Wait.
Oh my god, perfect.
Wait, but I kinda...
This is, what's her name from Ace Attorney, Dahlia?
Grimus?
No.
You'll see the vision once it happens.
Oh good.
Oh my god.
Wait, you could do bangs and stuff too?
You could do by the bangs and then you could do by the back?
Wait.
That's so cool.
Wait, what if I went different bangs?
Alright, spiky back.
No, no, no.
Spiky, spiky.
This is close.
I think this is our closest bet.
I'm not gonna lie.
Business in the front, party in the back.
How do some people look?
Get it where there's no bangs.
Can I do that?
I feel like this is the closest.
I've seen some crazy colors.
Subcolor?
How do I get there?
How do I...
Oh, there we go!
That's nice.
Oh, that's a nice little detail.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, can I do a subcolor here too?
Oh, oh.
I'm not really feeling it.
Oh, no.
Party in the back, baby.
Oh, it looks terrible.
What about this one?
No.
Make darker main color.
No, I already gave my reasoning.
Why I don't want to do that.
I like Gengar.
We just don't need a sub color.
here I think it's
kind of perfect hmm all right watch once we once we fix the
eyebrows there we go okay
give me a second I'm cooking wait where's my other ganglar
hold on i need to reference my second ganglar
i feel like maybe i do want to have a different
i think the spikier one because he has like the two you know
he has like the two wait i need it real spiky but there's
nothing spiky enough here okay hold on
This is not...
This is Dragon Ball.
Don't say that.
Alright, watch.
This is gonna change everything.
Are you ready?
Do you see the vision now?
I need the whole thing though.
Hold on.
Can we do the inside?
Whoa, these are freaky.
Whoa!
Whoa, this is fun.
What's undo?
Oh.
Wait, this is actually how Gengar is, though.
Sorry, guys.
It's not Sasuke.
Please, understand my vision.
Once he is...
Wait, okay, here we go.
Once...
Once he is in full, Gengar, you understand.
I wish I could make his eyes fully red on the inside, too.
I fear we might have to do, like, one of these.
What is this?
Oh, gosh.
Wait, I can draw it?
How do I do that, though?
Oh, is it this down here?
We're just going through each one real fast.
We'll go through each one and then we'll see.
Oh, that's how people have been getting like the super
intricate.
Okay, got it.
Okay, are you seeing it yet?
Are you seeing it yet?
I think it needs to be bigger.
Oh, I love those.
There it is.
I knew what I was doing.
Can you even see this?
No.
Big lobes.
I can't see anything.
That's okay.
Um, no glasses.
Oh.
Alright, so what is this?
Oh, these are just like other Cosmos.
He's pretty smooth, all things considered, so...
Honestly, he's pretty easy.
Okay, here we go.
Had face paint!
Swap between tools like the pen or eraser.
Wait, I'm using...
I'm using...
Wait.
The joycons.
Um...
Are you sure about the face shape?
Yeah.
I am?
I'm quite sure because he's a chunky guy.
He's very, you know.
Nimmy!
Thank you so much for the redirecting.
Paperbacks, thank you so much for the gifted.
Um, I'm making Gengar right now.
Wait, it's easier to draw here using touch controls.
Well, we're just gonna have to get, we're just gonna have to
do our best.
Wait, we can do this though.
Oh, there is a paint bucket.
Wait, what if I do this though?
Why isn't this showing up on his face?
By the way.
Oh, it's underneath!
No!
Dang it.
I think though it worked.
Honestly?
Oh, I have to get rid of the...
Oops, sorry.
I don't know where...
I don't know how to drive.
Sorry.
I didn't...
Oh, gosh.
What is pro?
Yes?
Oh!
Pro mode.
Tools merged with that have additional adjustable settings.
Try opening the settings.
We're pressing X.
Can I also change the color palette?
Y.
Switch back to easy mode.
There.
Oh, wait.
Uh, x-ray.
Oh, I clicked Y, my bad.
Lock transparency.
I can make it glow.
Okay, here's our little girl.
guinea pig, you know?
He's just our little guinea pig.
Wait, what color did I even use before?
I don't even know.
I can make text?
This is in...
Oh my gosh, I keep pressing.
There we go.
This is craziness.
Oh, here it is.
Whoa.
I'm not butchering him.
I'm experimenting.
What does this do?
Make him happy?
Illuminate?
Oh, that's what it'll look like.
Wait, I can do paint on top.
Okay, hold on.
How do I...
What is this?
Sparkle!
What does this do?
Ew.
Oh, he's just a square.
Mass L?
No!
This is not an L!
This is Gengar!
This is like a completely different series.
Please understand.
It's G!
It's G for Gengar.
Please understand!
Oh wait, I think I'm still on there.
This one.
Okay, this one.
We'll go real tiny.
Oh, this is tough.
This is...
he's this guy's tough okay all right we're doing our bust
here shoot okay he might be bleeding out the eyes a little
bit you could just blame the Ebola okay oh god you can zoom
oh r okay
Okay, you guys know how good my driving was, but wait until
you see how good my coloring is.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I'll just have to refill that in.
Don't worry about it.
One line at a time.
That's exactly what we're doing, baby.
Several of them at a time.
Shoot.
There is an eraser.
It's fine.
There's an eraser.
No one understands my artistic genius.
Wait, why is it like, there's like some...
There we go.
And thank you so much for the Akasubo!
Thank you!
Energy beam!
Ugh, I got dizzy.
I always press Y.
I don't need help.
No,
it's leaving a white line.
You see that?
I hope also, because I'm like, you know, I'm not feeling so
great today we're gonna do a shorter stream um i'm not gonna
take like an ultimate amount of time on the uh the the me
creation process so uh they might be what is color red wow
they might be a little like you know incomplete Oh, I didn't
even do more.
Why does it look so different in the preview than where it
looks like I'm drawing, you know?
What's happening here?
Am I being sabotaged?
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Yes!
Okay, I just gotta clean up his wings.
Right here.
Gotta make it look super like...
Yes, girl.
It's becoming Gengar.
For real.
But also, what I kind of want to do is do like this, too.
You want to know how I got these scars?
Let me try it again.
It looks so different in the camera preview.
Then it does here.
It's throwing me off.
Why is this here?
Why are you so serious?
The camera is 3D, but the drawing is flat.
I guess that makes sense, right?
I'm getting used to it.
You gotta be like a little dramatic about it.
Gotta be a little dramatic.
There's a select, copy paste, and mirror tool.
Oh, thank you.
It's not about the gym badges, it's about sending a message.
I wonder what their babies will look like once they're
married.
Oops.
That's okay.
There's an erase.
Just look like he's bleeding out a little bit, but he won't
be for long.
How does one mate the Gengar?
That's something you need to add.
Okay.
When Gengars really love each other.
They get really excited.
Sorry, not all of us are...
Oops.
Are getting Switch 2s.
I really do want to play Pokopia, though.
Not even just stream it.
Like, I just want to play the game.
But I think it's...
So crazy that...
Prices for consoles.
Even older consoles.
Like I think the Switch 1 went up even.
Which is so insane to me to think.
And then like the PS5 is going up again in price.
It's crazy.
So I've been like thinking about it.
But I was like there's some other things I need to save up
for.
Oh my gosh I can't get in there.
there we go so i'm holding off for now you know i'm trying
to be a little responsible
good enough good enough okay so then here we do this
okay almost so close yes Yes, all right.
And then, wait, no, it's a little.
No, well, maybe.
No, we'll try one more time.
Okay, we're so close.
Yes?
Okay.
Wait, is this white?
Yeah.
It looks blue.
Am I the only one seeing this?
Wait, it looks like it has a little bit of a bluish hue.
Am I crazy right now?
Wait, where the heck did this come from?
You've been staring at the red for too long?
I think so!
Ah yeah!
Alright, let's get you in.
Anything else?
Oh?
Oh wait, it looks like doo-doo.
What happened?
The ace cemetery makes him look crazier.
He's hungry for some snake.
RTX on.
I just had a crazy idea.
Wait a second.
I might be throwing all of my hard work away, everybody.
You can also layer face paint.
Oh!
Okay, so I was right.
Paint behind.
No, paint.
Trust the process.
Oh, some of it stays.
Some of it stays.
If I erase, does, like, the smile come back?
A little bit.
Yeah, actually.
Wait, that's kind of nice.
Okay, so I won't have to redo the smile.
Oh, X
is...
Actually, I could probably just do this, too.
Okay.
Oh no, I can't do that.
Just kidding.
Oh, dang it.
I lost it all.
So when I takes it all...
I think this one is my favorite.
Yeah!
You would say so, Miss Fiss.
Fellow Gengar lover.
In every way possible.
All right, so what I'm gonna do is watch this.
We're going to sculpt him like David.
Okay.
I think I need a really small...
Wait.
Like so.
Okay.
Is that fine?
Yeah?
That's looking good.
I lost it.
I had it and I lost it.
Oh shoot.
Alright, just wait for it.
Just wait for it.
Why isn't it showing up in the camera?
Oh, it kind of is.
Oh, it's because his head is too big.
Oh no!
We have to redo it.
Shoot.
Shrink the noggin.
Can I?
It kind of looks like he has like a an F-boy haircut,
doesn't it?
A little bit.
It looks like Guy Fieri.
No.
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna have to...
Hold on.
We're going to see if we can make his head smaller.
Everything is ruined.
Wait.
It's saved.
We're fine.
Oh, he's beautiful.
Thank you.
Oh, there's a couple more things we didn't get to last time.
to move or zoom.
Thank you!
Let me finish my art, please.
I'm in the middle of something.
Okay.
Wait, where's his head?
Oh, his head is still...
Okay, okay.
Ah, I can't draw the second one!
I fear it.
Does that mean Gengar likes using lick because he's trying
to get the flavor town?
Oh, yeah.
Me saying I wouldn't take so long on these.
But here I am.
Here I am perfecting.
I am making a Greek goddess.
I am... I am...
I am becoming literal Da Vinci over here.
Female Gengar?
Or... I think I actually... I think I made it a guy.
This is the game.
Daminki!
Daminki is here.
It's just gonna have to do.
It's just gonna...
Oh, I keep...
There we go.
Round it out.
It's gorgeous?
Stop it!
Oh, I should round this out too.
Round it out.
Nice.
And we'll fix the eyes, don't worry.
It belongs in the museum.
Thank you, Indy.
Yes.
Oh!
He got a little bit of a shave.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
We can fix this.
We can even this out.
A clean shave.
Oh wow, there was a straight tool this entire time.
Okay, this is the tough part, guys.
This is scary.
My life's work.
My afterlife's work is on the line here.
Okay.
Can we use the touchscreen?
Do you want to see what I'm doing?
Or...
I'm...
You don't trust me, do you?
Is that what you're saying?
You don't trust the process?
I think you just took out a snippet.
What about the fill tool?
I don't think it... Wait, let's see.
Do you think...
Do you think this would be obvious?
Wait a second.
Was this... Is this actually...
Oh,
it looks really bad.
No it doesn't!
Who said that?
Shame on you.
I can
add more spikes and stuff.
Gosh, that was a really handy tool, wasn't it?
It looks like he has like...
I know it's not part of the actual thing, but it just looks
like he, like, has marshmallow, like, he ate, like, s'mores
or something, and just has it all over his mouth.
It's so fresh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Serious.
This is serious.
This is really serious.
This is make or break.
Oh,
it looks like a little pokeball.
That looks so good, Minto!
We're on the fridge, do you want to hung up?
Oops.
You messed me up.
Now, he has a piercing.
Don't, don't distract me from my art, please.
It kind of looks like Gerard Way.
I think I need to make it a little less thick.
This one.
Okay.
Block transparency.
You can...
Why do you change the transparency?
Okay.
Let's try that again.
Alright.
Oops.
When I was a young ghost, a father took me into the city to
see a poke match.
You said one day I'll need you.
A phantom, because you're a ghost Pokemon.
And join the black parade.
When I was a young ghost, my father...
Oh!
Took me into the city to see your Pokemon.
Match me.
You just said, Simon, you ghost up.
To be the savior of the broken, the beaten, and the down.
I'm getting really used to...
To control...
Control...
C.
No.
That's... That's copy.
Wait.
How do you undo something?
I don't even know.
I think it's just muscle memory for me at this point.
controls it.
What was I thinking I am?
I'm giving a little bit more of a wing here.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
It might be perfect.
It might be great.
It might be grand.
I'm going to save myself the headache.
Alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
Pixel perfect?
Yes.
Always.
Pixel perfect?
Yes!
Actually, we'll do, oh yeah.
Blackyard.
Oh, I'm starting to fall asleep.
I still have been struggling a lot.
I took a nap earlier for about 30 minutes.
But last night I only slept for three hours so And the day
before too So I feel like I'm running on fumes here A little
sigh of relief when you surprise yourself By drawing the
lines good in less than 20 tries Yeah!
Make him slay girl I think he looks great
I think he's looking I think we're done
I think for me it's the very obvious um oh no wait there's
there's you wait i wait we gotta get the inside of his mouth
we gotta clean up his face we gotta get rid of the we gotta
get rid of the the Or maybe we don't.
Let's see what happens if I do this.
Damn.
The resemble is uncanny.
Oh, see, because there's a hole where the s'mores are.
People always say I'll sleep when I'm dead, but apparently
even that's not like...
I'm telling you!
Being a ghost is so...
Ugh.
outline the outline.
I'll do my best.
This face is...
It might be too much for me.
Oh!
There's just something about it.
That's really tickling.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Maybe we could just get his cheeks, you know?
Maybe we don't have to get the whole thing.
Maybe we just get the important bits.
It was really just the outsides, you know?
So maybe we don't have to do the whole thing, you know?
It's okay, don't worry about anything that I mess up.
I mess up?
No, I didn't.
making me I'm honored.
Is that Gengar in Total Dachi Knife?
Absolutely, baby!
Okay, let me fix his eye real quick.
What do I...
Let me fix his eye a little bit.
Maybe this is good.
This is good, isn't it?
Oh.
No.
Now he just looks tired.
I need my Minky Island.
It's cute like Minky, Minky!
Art Demand Suffering by Math.
This is high art.
Where, where, what math is involved here?
If only I didn't accidentally, oh my gosh.
If only I had an accidentally cut his eye off a little.
Yes, yes, yes.
We can, we can fix it.
I can put you back together.
It's like impossible to move a single pixel over.
Okay, now we go into here.
We pick the red.
And we fix this.
Use the D-pad.
Oh, thank you guys.
Yay!
It's not perfect, but it's much better.
It just looks like...
It looks like one out of a hundred of switch to...
Oh, no, no, it's okay.
I'll get a switch to eventually.
I just don't need one to know.
It's barely.
It's fine.
I think we're done.
Round little guy.
I mean, he's...
He's like... I don't know.
Actually, I think Ingar is quite tall.
He's like 4'11".
He's quite tall.
But I think it looks better if he's like...
Like that.
4'11?
Okay, when you look at Gengar, do you expect him to be that
tall?
I don't think so.
When I look at Gengar, I expect him to be like 2 feet tall.
Okay.
Name.
Your me is looking great!
Now let's get a few details about them.
I can always change this info later.
Name?
Gengar.
My name is Gengar.
Gengar?
Geng?
How do I make him say it right?
Gaa.
With an H.
My name is Jengar.
Jengar.
You had it right the first time!
Oh, gang?
My name is Jengar.
No, it's not.
Gang?
Yeah, someone did this.
Do I think...
Do we need the space?
We could try it.
Oops.
Gar.
My name is Gengar Yeah!
Wait, I wonder though if I...
My name is Gengar.
If I put not the space.
You know?
Let's try.
My name is Gengar.
Never mind.
No, it's not.
Okay, never mind.
We need that.
We need the Gengar.
Okay.
My name is Gengar.
Okay, cool.
I don't know.
Okay, wait, I don't think anybody knows.
Right?
Like, if it's two guys, do they have a baby?
Do they mix their genes?
I want to see what the Gengar baby will look like.
You know what I mean?
Can everybody have a baby together?
all the babies of Gengar.
They just work.
I think, though, because Gengar is a Pokemon, we'll do
non-binary.
Dating preferences?
Everybody.
Everybody is gonna be into everybody.
There will be no off...
Nothing is off limits.
Everybody...
Nothing...
No.
Everybody will be able to get with anybody.
I like calling them.
a little guy, though, so we'll go with that.
What style does Gengar prefer?
In the wedding dress.
Either is okay.
Gengar's birthday.
In this world, grown-up mees are 18 or older.
You can make them not age?
Let's do October 31st.
Age?
Born in 2007.
Now, why the hell would you say that?
You're okay with Gengar having babies, but it's a problem
when all the Ibu's get pregnant.
Double standards much, Minto.
This game...
Why would it put that?
Put born in 2007.
That's not real.
People are not born after 2005.
Oh,
yeah.
It's just, oh, it hurts.
Oh.
What, in the AO3?
I thought they only had Mega Gengar, not Omega Gengar.
It turns
into dust.
Just a kid.
I'm just a kid.
Wait, born in...
150.
Born in 2025?
If you're zero, you're not born at all.
Pokemon is 30 Oh, that's a good way to do it That's a good
way to do it Pokemon is 30 years old 30 years old Everybody
in 1995 I'm looking at you I'm looking at you I'm forever 19
so I can't relate You know
My name is Gengar It's nice to meet you My name is Gengar My
name is Gengar.
My name is Gengar.
It's nice to me.
Oh my god.
Today is March 30th, 2026.
How does this voice sound?
The sound is Gengar.
It's nice to me.
Today is March 30th.
26.
It sounds like- It's too good!
Okay, Gengar is a little slow.
It's too good!
He's on the slower side.
I think Gengar would be pretty honest.
The energy...
We're varied than...
No, like, he's kind of chill.
And he's pretty chill.
And Gengar is overall...
Quirky.
Sorry, my head is blocking the quirky.
But Gengar is a quirky, quirky guy.
My dog heard it and just ran away.
Consider it amicable, thoughtful, honest, innocent.
Does things at their own pace.
This doesn't seem... I think we got the wrong thing.
I think I messed up somewhere.
But that's okay.
Hopefully that seems to fit.
That moment Gengar sounds more like Galaga.
to their personality types.
The colors in that palette will show up in different ways
like in their clothing and their default color of their
house.
Oh yeah, Daydream Eater because he's eating the dreams.
Oh, good, good, good one.
Nice save, nice save.
Oh, it's terrible.
It's the fact that he will say literally one word.
It's now in...
Oh, it's so...
Ah!
Where's my goopo?
We'll change the voice, don't worry.
Thank you for the hug, goopo.
But don't do that!
He will get one word in normal and then the rest is just
squeaking.
That's true, Jerome.
I'll come back over, take her.
You are awesome.
I'm still in a snake.
Dream eater.
Oh, what should you call me?
The top dog!
Top dog?
I appreciate it.
Should you be staying up so long to chat with me?
Chat with me!
No one over 40 can even hear a king guard talk.
Boss!
Well, because I say big boss.
I'm gonna be big boss.
Big.
Boss.
I can't understand what he's saying.
I don't know what he's just communicating with me and I
don't understand
any time if you want me to call you something else oh by the
way what's your master
Wow, they only expect the longevity of this game to last
until 2060.
They only expect this game to last like 30-some years?
It sounds like one of those flashlights you charge by
squeezing it.
No!
Next Tomodachi Life, you heard it here first, folks.
2060.
The game is auto-saving.
Okay, good.
Okay, how do I fix you?
Oh, he looks at a feelings bubble has appeared over Gengar's
head.
It means this me is pondering something.
Let's try talking to Gengar to see what's up.
Let's see what's on this me's mine.
Michael Davies from Faith.
Like the game?
I'm finished.
And me.
Looks like Gengar is hungry!
That should be easy to handle.
If only we weren't on a remote island.
Why did you move here then?
Store.
Is he gonna work there too?
Babby's first, uh...
First part-time job?
Now snacks aren't free, but since we're celebrating the
addition of your first island, resident...
Here's $200!
Let's go, thank you!
Check out the food mart and see if there's something that
Gengar would like to eat.
There's no way to support you sticking out.
It's so cute!
Daily specials.
Shop for stuff you previously bought.
Let's get everything.
A plie-plee?
Fried egg.
Butter cookie.
Baked until golden.
Or perhaps as the butter.
So, so much butter in there.
And nachos!
Why are eggs so expensive again?
For a single egg.
Mind you.
One egg is $3.80.
Insanity.
on Bucket of Frogs Branch, I mean on...
Yay!
My birthday was on the 22nd!
Jackpot!
Happy!
I'm sorry, I'm late!
Bye.
I love this voice and I love it and hate it at the same
exact time.
Like, how do I change it?
I don't think I can yet.
It's okay.
Oh my gosh, you see his little face there?
Give me his gifts.
Food time!
Select the food.
I'm gonna give him the single egg.
Not the react.
He only liked it.
We'll keep trying.
Oh, the happiness goes up.
Nice!
Happiness will increase when you help them resolve an issue.
Some good stuff is likely to happen if you keep them happy.
What the heck was that?
We got paid!
Oh, warm fuzzies.
Warm fuzzies are mysterious orbs that appear when me's are
happy and grateful.
Gengar voice is so bad.
Do you not hear me saying that I'm trying to change it?
Don't be a hater.
Come on.
Oh, please never change it.
Oh.
I don't know.
I don't know if I can stand it anymore.
I can't read.
Zero guide.
I'm my own hater.
No, we'll change the door.
No, I don't want to go back out.
I want to give him something else.
Okay, it's forcing us to leave.
We're in total tutorial mode right now.
That's okay.
Wow.
Good evening to you.
What is he?
Is there blinking underneath there?
Free!
Get strong, Jerome.
Now come back away, Tom and Sidero!
Hey, Robin!
I
know what he's saying.
It's so funny.
His pronunciation is pretty good.
It's almost, it's like a pitched up version of one of those
like, those yuinkie sploinkie tubes that go like, wow, wow.
Every time.
It's so peak.
No, I don't know if it's a slide whistle.
It's so funny.
Oh, the groin, gro- not groin, the groan tooth.
I'm crying.
Feels like the island is coming alive with a meal.
You're in charge now, so take good care of your meals and
have fun living on...
Yay!
Strong, won't you?
Welcome back.
It's a wee, whiz, a wee!
I don't remember the pronunciation.
One more thing.
What is it, Columbo?
I don't think anyone else could have made that me, though.
Make sure you save your progress before closing the game.
What a voice we got on the first poll.
You can save at any time.
Just press X.
Is the island where Gengar was banished to?
island full of total absolute rejects.
Oh, geez.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I think I accidentally closed.
Hold on.
I closed out of my game.
Or not.
There we go.
I'm playing through OBS, obviously.
Keep the voice.
I doubt we'd hit goal.
I want to see it if it shows like the sliders, you know, for
it.
Because if it dies...
Dropping in on Ganglar?
Oh, he's so sad.
What's wrong?
I hate the girl.
I gotta grab him.
Ooh, I'm a spooky ghost.
I'm a spooky ghost.
What's X there?
Where is it?
Oh, here we go.
Edit voice, maybe?
Okay, this Ganglar.
Oh no, uh, uh, close, close.
Edit body made.
Oh, voice custom.
Here we go.
Anybody?
Wait.
If you guys want this voice.
2826.
So, how does this voice sound?
Here, here.
Oh my god, shut up, please.
This March 30th, 2026.
If anybody wants to...
There you go.
What if I do it like...
My name is Gengar.
I mean...
I hear the pitch is...
My name is Gengar.
It's nice to meet you.
This is better.
Today is March 30th, 2026.
So, my name is Gengar.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is March 30th, 2026.
Yeah, we'll do this one.
How does this voice sound?
My name is Gengar.
It's nice to meet you.
Today, my name is Gengar.
Today is March 30th, 2020.
My name is Gengar.
Alright.
It's too divisive, you guys, so we're just gonna change it.
It's okay.
Again, if you like the voice, I gave you the custom
parameters for it.
You can make it your own.
Okay.
Nice to meet you.
What's wrong?
Um.
Good evening.
Hello.
What's wrong?
More.
I require more food.
I heard you can bonk mews with other mews once you can pick
them up.
Really?
Wait, that's so cute.
Let's try the nachos.
Maybe he'll love this.
Who doesn't love nachos?
Yum.
He liked it.
He didn't like it more than a single egg.
What's wrong with this guy?
He leveled up.
Every time that happens, you get to give the meat a gift.
You give the meat a little quirk.
You're giving them a new personality trait.
Little quirks can make the meat act more like the person
they're based on.
Why not?
Give out plenty and watch how your me's behavior changes.
You can always change them later.
Oh.
Greets proudly.
Eww!
His mouth disappeared.
His mouth...
Eww!
Stan's cute.
They try to look cute in an attempt to ward off haters.
Oh, we can only do the two, okay.
Stan's like a rodeo rider.
Gamer posture?
Oh, that's so good!
That's good!
Oh, he's wiped.
I need it for us a lot.
I need it for for us a lot.
We'll do this one.
Show me!
Oh, I feel a little different.
Show me.
Looks like things are going well.
Speaking of making me happy, what would happen if you gave
this one a head rub?
Don't be shy, put your hand on Gengar's head and give it a
little rub.
You can use the touchscreen.
Damn it, I don't have it.
Oh my god.
For everybody who put me on your island, did you do this
too?
She really liked that!
Poor money, baby.
You've collected a fair amount of warm fuzzies.
What are the warm fuzzies for?
Oh!
Oh my god, the news.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
A wishing fountain has been constructed on.
Yay!
Get strunger on.
Welcome back away, Tomeinsiderone.
The island's resident is excited, quoted as saying, finally,
somewhere to take a bath.
It was me.
I'm the island's resident.
It was me!
I interviewed myself for this report.
Thanks for watching.
You're welcome.
I'm Gengar, and you're off today.
Yay!
New facility!
Oh, where are warm fuzzies?
I've reached level one.
One wish.
Oh, he's a little fairy.
Your island now has a wishing fountain.
It will grant wishes in exchange for warm fuzzies.
It sounds like Zelda.
Like Team Muzelda.
Okay.
He lives here by himself.
It had to be him.
I think he's going insane.
The more wishes you grant, the more you'll unlock.
Plus you're likely to unlock even more as the island comes
along.
You notice that you've collected a lot of warm fuzzies.
It's a good time to stop by the fountain.
More quirks.
Walking style.
Reverse?
Add these to the little quirks.
Yes.
Oh, I probably should get some items too though, huh?
Yay!
What are you, Deku?
Oh, he's out!
What about?
Nevermind.
He's upset?
What's wrong?
Um...
Good evening.
Hello!
Why are you upset?
It's so lonely, being the only person on you.
Get strungerone.
Welcome back away, Tomen Siderone.
Kind of gives me the heebie-jeebies too.
Two.
I wish there were other people here with me.
Me?
Gangar is hoping for a new resident.
This is the perfect chance to try adding another me.
The heck is that name?
It's literally the pronunciation of the island.
Press X to open it.
All right.
Atomy!
Vacancy.
All right, Gengar.
Thank you.
You did your job here.
Now, which snake do I reference?
Hmm.
I'm looking at all my snakes.
Snake, though.
might not be as uh what's the word she might not be as drawn
in you know we might follow like a
solid I was thinking of MGS2 snake
saying welcome to the ghost parade of working on your
beautiful Gengar creation Tobanachi live lifting it lifting
it up already made my day much better thank you ah thank you
for the spooky donut Sorry, that's been a rough day for you.
No.
Let Gengar heal you.
Okay, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, we gotta give him the mullet like this.
And then if we give him bangs...
Wait, wait.
No!
Why would you do this to me?
Okay, hold on.
Mullet.
It looks...
It looks terrifying.
Maybe not so long.
No, it's gotta be longer.
Oh, that's a bit better.
She's gotta have that, though.
Is that Apollo justice?
Okay.
Trust the vision.
Trust
the vision.
Trust the vision.
What kind of eyes do I want him to have, though?
MGS2 Snake relaxing in Tomodachi after Rainbow Six.
Not the Rainbow Six.
Okay, he doesn't have like that crazy of blue eyes.
That looks a bit better.
Can't wait to see you rub Walter's bald head.
Walter.
Oh my god, I'll give him every...
I'll give him cookbooks.
I'll give him beakers.
It'll be so exciting.
Welta.
No, I think I like this one better.
And then we can draw on his headband.
So that might fix his big old forehead, you know?
That might help with his forehead.
Sorry.
I was waiting for it to come.
I feel like I'm sneezing every stream now.
What's happening to me?
I never was a sneezer.
Now I'm only sneezing.
Thank
you.
What is...
Snake's got a pretty big nose.
Maybe like this one.
Oh yeah, yeah.
That's the snage.
Yeah.
That's it.
Oh wait, I forgot to change the eye type, my bad.
Let's see.
Um...
Hmm.
Oh, I'll have to change.
Oh.
Why does this one suit him so well, though, you know?
I like this one.
I think that one.
Or this one or this one.
The guy has got eye bags.
It's just a fact.
We can lift the.
eyebrows up a bit.
No, they gotta be.
Oh, rotate it.
You're right, right?
We'll rotate it to the...
Oh, and I'll go down a little.
And we'll make his eyebrows a bit bigger.
Oh, bigger, I said.
Hmm.
It does kind of look like the plushie I have, actually.
We're still cooking?
we're still cooking oh my god that's just a butthole that's
literally a butthole that's pom-pom pudding's butthole eat a
lemon that's him Oh, wait, no, this is so good.
This is him saying, Black one.
Black one.
Let him know, Minto.
It's a butthole.
Through and through.
We'll do this one.
It looks better, I think.
Black one.
Can we even see his ears?
Oh, we can!
He's got big old ears.
No.
Okay, here we go.
He's got his eye bags.
He's even got like...
It's not like...
Snake always has like a...
I guess this is best.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
And then since this is MGS2 Snake...
Wow.
MGS2 Snake is only a beard.
It's not like...
a full red one metal gear solid to snack oh no it's the full
thing oh my god oh yeah he's got the whole thing he's
malnourished no he's not this is literally what he looks
like
no man has ever been angrier looks
like that pliskin fella that's because he doesn't have that
bandana on yet we'll get there we'll get there right and get
this man a shaver what was it wait wait hold on i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go double check i have an arsenal of references
yeah i was right even on the official on the official like
things for him like uh little little toys on my little lego
man of him they give him this
And my little Lego man is MGS2 Snake.
So you guys are all wrong!
Everybody's wrong except me.
I'm the biggest fan.
I'm an arsenal of references.
His head is pretty round.
Maybe we should make it less round, huh?
I think that's what's throwing me off about it.
His head being so round.
Oh!
Oh my god, the crimson chain.
Something like that.
I don't think Snake is actually very tall, though.
The expert has spoken.
I have looked at that man so many times.
I never stopped trusting the process.
Thank you!
I knew you'd believe in me.
His head is just so small.
Oh, he just feels small.
We'll go with this one.
Oh, yeah.
Flambé!
No, hold on.
We're going to change everybody's opinions in two seconds,
okay?
Copy another me's paint?
Oh, no.
Okay, all right, let's see.
This is where it gets tricky.
Because we have to paint on top.
We gotta make sure his little tuft stays.
Okay, it's gonna be like a really big bandana.
Please understand.
Like so long.
I wonder if I should make it go to the end of it.
But it like...
I guess I should make it go to the end of his head, huh?
Color the forehead but not the hair.
I know we have to cover his eyebrows but like it'll be so
big then it'll be the largest ever also I think what's
throwing hold on I think what's throwing me off about him
too is his hair is not fuzzy enough right I wish there I
wish we could have the tuft the little front bang but it'd
be like fluffier on top, you know?
Ew.
We could do something like this, like something that covers
his head a little bit more.
But...
We then cover over the other bangs and leave a little tough,
do you know what I mean?
Pliskin mode.
Draw on the bang
How can you be so Right No
It's still not right
Does it work like that?
It could But look at this It works, it looks so good When
it's like, what does this one look like?
Nah Maybe like this and then I
He just looks like a shonen protagonist now.
I feel like this one worked the best.
You know?
Let's try this again.
I
don't exactly cover his...
His eyebrows.
That's okay, though.
Oh, oops.
Alright.
There are probably guides for this.
No, we do it raw, we do it raw.
Because then, no matter how we do it, we don't have to draw
anything.
No matter how we do the headband.
So it's kind of nice, I think.
Maybe?
That's how it works.
We can color in the background here, so it looks like he's
got more hair.
He looks like he's got more hair.
Oh, there we go.
All right.
The process.
the process.
Oh, deep out, deep out.
There we go, there we go.
Yes.
Okay.
Now, can I buck it?
Okay!
I feel like we shouldn't make it go around his head because
we physically cannot do that.
What if we can make it a bit longer?
We'll make it a bit longer.
It's gonna have to stop at some point.
Okay.
It's all coming together.
Yeah.
So it just disappears into his head.
You know?
It's fine.
Kind of like what they do with...
Why is it sitting on top of him?
Whatever.
We don't care.
Oh my gosh.
When you hold it down, it's so fast.
It'd be zooming.
Okay.
All right, now here, can I do this?
No.
Okay.
We're going to have to guess the hair.
What is this one?
Oh, yeah, we don't care.
I'm just trying to fill it in.
Oh, it has it over here.
That's so nice.
They give you the hair color.
That's good.
Oh, I guess it does kind of match.
I mean, it matches, but there's also the...
The shading that makes it a little funny.
But that's okay.
Yeah, it looks better on the preview for sure.
Oh, wait a second.
Wait, where'd that color come from?
Did I actually select that?
Oops.
Okay.
I wish I could get the secondary color.
Huh?
Where is this color coming from?
Why do you want me to select that?
Oh, it doesn't really work though.
He's got bald spots.
Oh, there it is.
It's fine even if he has bald spots.
Okay, wait, I'm actually doing it.
I'm doing it!
It's a little funky, but it doesn't matter!
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
We're doing it!
We're doing something!
I'll get rid of that.
Trusting the process?
It looks like him now, though, don't you think?
What are we thinking?
How are we feeling?
One, two, one.
We're mollit!
It's as good as we're gonna get, I think.
Solid effort.
I understood that reference.
Oh,
and he's also pretty thick.
Oh, Gengar?
Get it?
Ooh.
Uh.
Cha-cha, real smooth.
A cute little pose.
What will their babies look like?
What?
Oops.
What will their babies look like?
I can't wait for them to have babies too.
My name is Snake.
Okay.
We'll make you go.
You're...
Oh.
Where's his birthday?
Saw?
I feel like it's gonna be like January 1st, snake birthday.
1972.
Oh, it doesn't give like a...
It doesn't give a...
what's it called though a date he was born in that we'll do
January because that's so like you know like January 1st
it's like a default you know
I worked insanely early today which means I got off early
and I can watch your stream I've been working on my first
gumblet kit ever while watching you play it's been lovely
vibe oh and we're having fun oh wait 78 wait was it 78
72.
54 years old.
My name is Snake.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is March 30th, 2020.
My name is...
my name is snake it's nice my name is snake it's nice to my
name is snake i'm trying to see if i can get one oh god it's
nice to meet you this is basically Old Gengar.
My name is Snake.
It's nice to...
It's nice to me.
My name is Snake.
It's nice to meet you.
Okay, what's the...
My name is Snake.
Today is March 30th, 2026.
My...
My name is...
My name is Snake.
It's nice to meet you.
Don't smoke kids or your sound like this.
Today is March 30th, 2020.
My name is Snake.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is March 30th, 20th.
My name is Snake.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is March 30th, 2026.
Why do you say it?
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is... My name is Snake.
It's nice to me.
My name... My name is Snake.
My name is...
My name is Snake.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is March 30th, 2026.
So...
How does this voice sound?
My name is Snake.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is...
Is real world snake related to anyone on this island?
He's going to be kind of quick.
She's stealthy, so he's mostly slow.
He's, like, pretty honest.
But this is a solid snake we're talking about.
This is not, like, big boss.
Hey, KCN2, thanks for the get-thin!
Energy is, uh, it's in the middle.
The dating preferences.
Oh, thank you.
First thing glitches, thanks for the get-thin!
Thinking is, uh, serious.
Serious, man.
A little less serious.
Overall, he's kind of quirky.
Uh, dating preferences.
Everybody.
Ah, well, thanks so much for the vibe, get-thin!
Thank you!
Oh!
Ambitious and confident!
A buy the book straight talker puts a premium on results.
Gapu, thanks for the five githards!
Diligent, productive, and highly efficient.
Because he's a soldier!
Equally as skilled at planning and executing plans!
Oh my god!
I think we made Snake for real.
In his blue little hut.
Um...
Hey...
You must be big boss.
It's nice to me.
you my name is snake i'm an ambitious achiever i focus on a
goal and don't stop until i hit it oh as long as i stay
focused i can do anything thanks in advance for looking
after me here oh thank you all right um Gengar I heard
someone named Snake just moved to yay get strungerone
welcome back away Tominsiderone wait I think I made them
each have the same inflection oh my bad which do you like
better cats or dogs cats cats I like bugs wait let me see if
I can I was like, scoot.
Maybe I'll scoot, like, here for the stream.
I feel like I'm covering up so much all the time.
Bugs.
Oh.
Not really what I asked.
But if you like them, then so do I.
I?
Denchi, please submit chance.
The more of...
Denchi, do this.
The more my voice will blend in so I can hide better.
We have a lot of submissions.
Thank you for all the density who have submitted their
voices for the secret project that is happening.
Thank you!
The deadline is tomorrow, I believe.
BFG players, thank you!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
That solid snake or a wavy snake?
Oh, here, I'll give you a headbutt.
The FNAF children saying, yeah.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, now that your island has two residents, you should help
them get to know each other!
Okay, we're gonna go look.
Me and Gar's here.
Okay.
Oh, that snake is here.
Put the cursor on and me and then hold A.
Nice grab.
Thank you.
Ugg Ugg Pardon me Could I have a moment?
My name is Snake Nice to meet you, Snake I'm Gengar
Appointances Oh they're so beautiful next to each other
Snake is trying to greet Gengar but keeps getting distracted
by his sense of fashion You guys are wearing the same
friends seems like minded now I'm closer with Gengar thank
you thank you you're welcome oh looks like they have fun
chatting with each other that's great by guiding these
together you can help them get to know each other and grow
closer they'll develop relationships on their own but a
little helping hand can Thank you.
Try guiding them into each other's path again sometime soon.
Something different is likely to happen.
All right, soon you said.
Come, all right, come here.
Big boss.
Gengar is inviting Snake to chat using the gentle approach
of, so, listen to this.
Why did he go?
do that oh
i thought it'll ah he loved it he loved it
you're so funny thanks for your help there i feel like snake
and i get along a little better now
oh good let's go on to see sam yeah they're laughing about
the everyday struggles they face in life Like being alone on
an island.
Oh, bye!
Let's see.
Snake has a problem.
Let's head inside.
Oh, look at him!
He looks inside!
Um.
Um?
Good evening.
What's your problem, Snake?
What's your problem?
I want to be friends with Gengar.
Great thinking!
What should we talk about?
Let's see.
Why don't you give them something to talk about?
What would be a fun topic?
Oh no, here it comes.
What did you have in mind?
Well, that you like for 3DS will always be my favorite.
I don't know.
This one's really great so far.
A person, a thing, an activity.
Hmm.
An activity.
The activity they should talk about is sneaking?
Probably like sneaking.
I'm like, do I want to be on brand for snake or do I want to
be a little silly?
You know?
Do we want to?
Snake and Gengar put me out of my misery.
Do we want to be a little freaky?
A little silly.
Wait.
Wait, can I change?
Hold on.
Let's see.
What did you have in mind?
Hold on.
I think I got one.
Person they should talk about is...
Mowing man.
Meowing man.
The meowing man.
Got it.
I'll go talk to him about meowing man.
Meowing man.
Good evening, Gengar.
Do you feel like talking about...
Meowing man.
Miaoing Man.
Funny you should bring that name up.
Wait, how do you feel about Miaoing Man?
Well, I think Miaoing Man is pretty funny.
Yeah, I feel the same way.
I think we're on the same way playing.
Snake, let's be friends.
Yes, yes!
Yeah!
Miaoing Man.
Wow, they're not even just friends, they're good friends.
What's options?
What will we call Gengar when talking to others?
Ew, what's this mannequin over there?
Oh my god, this is so detailed.
What will be his nickname?
Hold on, I think I got it.
Gengar!
When Snake gets injured, he goes, Ah, Gengar.
Hey, Gengar.
It's like the exact same.
Because of his inflection, his accent.
Literally, not even any different.
Gengar.
How goes it?
Oh, Gengar.
I'm glad do my inhaler real quick.
I have to do two every four hours.
I have to wait a minute in between.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 29, 20, 21, 22, 26, 27, 27,
29, 30, 31, 32, 16, 34, 35, 36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 41, 32, 46,
47, 48, 49, 50, 31, 32, 53, 54, 55, 56, 57, 58, 59, 6.
Too fast?
Me!
Ganga goa!
Ha, ha, ha.
Hey.
Ganga.
Go.
Hey.
Ganga goa.
It works, okay, hold on.
I think I'm gonna change, because they both have the same, I
like snakes so much, though.
So we're going to change the way Gengar talks again.
Even though he's the OG.
But I like snakes so much more.
Good evening.
Snark.
Looks like Gengar and I are friends now.
I'm always down to chat with Snark.
These two have become friends!
Me start as strangers, but their relationships will develop
in all sorts of ways as they grow closer.
Snock!
Friends, sweethearts, and beyond!
Beyond, sweethearts!
You get to watch their relationships blossom and maybe even
nudge them slightly in one direction or another.
Snock!
The more residents you have on your island, the more ways
they can be.
can connect with each other but back to these two they're
the island's first pair of friends which is a huge deal
around here let's see if they made the local news what we
interrupt to bring you some breaking news here's what's
happening on our island this broadcast audience is about to
double as another resident can now live on yay get strunger
own welcome back away tome inside a We've also heard that a
wear and wear clothing may open sometime after a third
resident moves in.
This reporter's advice, get that thread.
Get that thread.
Thanks for watching.
Thank you.
I'm Gengar and you're off today.
His eyes are all messed up.
It's fine though.
They're sleeping together on the floor.
Oh, they're, sorry, they're lazing about.
How's it going?
I'm
going to give you an apple, and it's going to be your
favorite thing ever.
A ploppy.
Let's give Snake something, too.
They're in max chill mode.
Are they about to kiss?
No.
Who knows?
I don't know, baby.
You get the last thing I have.
A butter cookie!
I'm going to have to speed run the third thing, I think, you
guys.
Sorry, my cough is getting much worse.
He also really liked it.
Give him a tree from.
Who should I last?
Maybe.
Look at them hanging out They look so cute Oh yeah Oh yeah
So it said we could get threads I think we have to Get the
last guy first Oh whoops We could do
Astro bot Astro bot Frogbert!
Okay, we'll make Frogbert.
I need a reference.
We said easy, but...
Being green ain't easy.
Sorry, I lost my screen.
Okay.
You guys will just have to trust the process here, okay?
Guys might just have to trust the process here.
Bald.
Oh wait, I forgot.
Duh.
He's gotta be green!
Like a lime.
I cough.
What sucks is...
Tomorrow I wanted to finish Bioshock, but that would be a
much longer stream.
And I don't want to just not talk on it, you know, the whole
time.
I'm debating what to do.
Debating, debating.
I wonder, I didn't even get to see it, like, I guess there
are.
Like, I think this.
Okay.
Make them bigger.
Shrink them.
Actually.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
We had the one eye, didn't we?
This one.
Oh, but it needs to be full.
I think we might have to draw it again.
I think we might have to draw the inside.
red again also I need to change this to black what
if it's none hmm or we do something we do like a little
something like this you know this way oh wait even tinier oh
it's reminding me of something and I'm not sure what you can
remove the lashes of this one even oh you're right oh my
gosh huge this game is so customizable actually now that I'm
seeing it hold on his eyebrows should be like this according
to the model but this these eyes are too slit like they're
too slanted they need to be round so maybe we
Go with this.
And then we draw it in ourselves.
I was going to do the tiny eyes and then, you know, draw it
over.
But for the sake of my sanity, we will do as minimal drawing
as we can.
How could you?
Oh, he looks happy right now.
Looks like a happy little guy.
But he's not supposed to be.
We'll do like that.
There we go.
Okay.
This one's too sexy.
This one is so sexy.
Oh my god.
Oh, what's wrong?
Oh.
What does this mean?
Oh, with lips or without?
Interesting.
Hmm.
You can remove the lipstick.
Wait, what does it look like for this one then?
Because this is funky.
That's so funny!
I love it.
Have you ever seen the show Bob's Burgers?
Yeah, I have!
Why?
Oh, this is good.
That's good, that's good.
Ears, none.
You can also add lipstick.
What?
Oh my gosh!
The customization, I feel like, I mean, I know people could
go for like hours just doing this, you know?
Alright, so with this...
If I paint behind...
Wait, but I did paint behind.
Wait, I'm confused.
Wait, but it's still painting on top.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, okay, never mind.
It's just the eyes and stuff.
Okay, actually that works even better.
Rung, rung, rung, rung, rung, rung, rung.
Thanks for the buy gifted!
Rusty, glitch face.
Thank you for the gifted.
I think I will see you.
in a minute can i get a happy birthday shout out for my
coming actually roger go happy birthday happy happy birthday
raiders oh i'm so sorry i didn't see you like bob's burgers
is my favorite show i do like bob's burgers i
just spilled tea all over myself
it won't stay on behind if you no no we want it on behind oh
wait both the eyes okay we'll do we'll do his headpiece
Oh, that already looks so good.
Oh, wait.
It's kind of...
It's fine.
It doesn't have to be perfect.
Oh, what is it?
Oh, why?
That's right.
Let's see.
Like that?
Yeah.
And then...
Reset the camera.
There we go.
Ah, Minto, she can't draw in a straight line.
She can't draw in any line.
Oh, she's so quirky like that.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
We'll fix it up.
We'll clean it up!
Um,
wait.
No.
Zoom in.
I'm down.
She's just like me, for real, for real.
So we all have problems.
It's, like, easier once you get the momentum, you know what
I mean?
No, it's not.
Just kidding, I lied.
I lied?
She lied as easily as she breathed.
I'm dead.
I don't need to breathe.
That's better.
Is there like a...
Oh, there is a shape tool.
Okay, perfect.
We're gonna do that.
Wait.
For the eyes.
I think there was probably a fill version.
Oh, we're on the fill version?
Okay, perfect.
Now, how does this work?
Oh, my God, so nice.
Wait, so I can...
Wait.
I can make it bigger or smaller.
How do I make it bigger?
You know?
Amazing ghostly goober!
If I were to add you as an NPC for a TNT group, what would
you want to be?
Um...
I want to be...
Wait.
Oh, I think I'm flipping it.
Oh, there we go.
I want to be!
Eww!
Bard?
No, no.
I want to be.
Oh, oh, it's all or nothing, isn't it?
Oh, that sucks.
Why is it glowing?
I want to be.
Illumination is max.
Oh, did I accidentally do that?
Oh, there, oh, that's why.
Oh, I see, I see, okay.
All right.
Next circle.
I
felt like I almost had it.
Oh,
Z-R.
What's plus?
Oh, undo.
Uh-oh, undo.
Wait, there it is.
Ah!
Oh, no, undo.
Wait, do it again?
Have mirror mode?
I think so, but it's fine.
We're so close.
We got this.
We got this team.
Look, that is so close to being mirrored anyway.
Okay, now we just do his eyes, and we're good.
And then also...
Okay, it's paint on top.
Good.
Alright.
Don't you worry, you're pretty little hit.
Oh.
We'll start over.
It's really every time I laugh, man.
Close enough.
You guys wanted Frogbert.
How are you feeling?
How are we feeling about him, guys?
How are we feeling about Frogbert?
I am still trying.
I mean, it's almost done.
You either see the vision now or you don't see it at all.
You don't see my vision.
Which is it?
Are you with me or are you against me?
Oops.
You see the vision?
MCUS sees the vision.
It's my birthday!
I'm looking forward to the dance and two concert.
Thank you!
I kind of want to change the shape, I think.
Oh, that was good.
That was clean.
So many birthdays today.
Happy birthday to everybody.
Sorry, I can't sing.
Only Sith deal in absolute minke.
Hmm?
Frogbert is the tallest one here, by the way.
My name is Frogbert.
Everybody?
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot the dating preferences again.
There we go.
Everybody is into... Oh, I don't know.
I'm just gonna close my eyes.
September!
Third!
Is it...
Is it loop?
Oh, I think it did.
Wait.
24?
This guy?
To reference his third movie, Anakin tells Obi-Wan you're
either...
Oh yeah, you're either with me or against me.
Obi-Wan tells him only Siths deal in absolutes.
My name is Frogbert.
It's nice to meet you.
That's kind of close.
My name is Frogbert.
It's nice.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Frogbert.
Today is March 30th.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Frogbert.
My name is...
Today is March 30th, 2026.
My name is Frogbert.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is March...
My name is Frogbert.
Oh god, oh god.
It's nice.
My name is Frogbert.
Why is it getting worse?
It's nice to me.
My name is Frogbert.
My name is...
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Frogbert.
Today is March 3rd.
It's nice to meet you.
We'll go with this one.
Is there just something about it?
Nope.
He's like kind of slow.
His speech is very honest.
His energy...
I'd say it's like more flat than anything.
This guy is chill, chill, chill.
Frogbert turned into GLaDOS for a second.
Overall?
Quirky, dude.
This is just a weirdo.
Frogbert!
Got him!
The
mystic and passionate follows their instincts.
Outgoing and pleasant to be around makes friends easily and
can turn any bad situation into a good one!
We have fuzzies.
What do we get?
Hey there.
It's nice to meet you, big boss.
I'm Frogbert.
I'm an outgoing merrymaker.
I'm a social butterfly who loves hanging out with friends.
Leave it to me, and I'll find the fun and anything.
I can't wait to start living here.
Thank you.
All right, let's go to the fountain.
Wait, what's why?
Oh, wait, did Snake fall asleep?
Snake!
I'm watching him.
Wait, is he dreaming?
Don't push me, okay?
I'm definitely not chickening out.
No.
He's gonna do it.
I want to enjoy this view a moment longer.
Puts the sun in arson.
Ah.
Oh.
Oh my god.
This is dangerously close.
Are you okay, Snake?
Ah.
Maybe I'm more now.
We got a weak looking elastic rope.
Oh my gosh, it's just like the first game.
It's so good.
We got treasure.
Wondering what to do with it?
Well, maybe there's a me on your island who would be
delighted to receive...
Frogbert.
Oh, uh, what's up?
What's up?
Bye.
Oh, this is probably a good time to mention that all the
various items you obtain will be recorded in your item
catalog.
Check it out sometime by pressing the X.
Oh, it wants us to check it out right now.
We got a treasure.
We have a...
Treasure number?
Uh...
2-2-9!
Who am I gonna give this to?
Why?
They feel like there's such few goods.
Oh, I want the moroccas!
We're gonna give the moroccas to somebody.
Just you wait.
The wishing fountain.
Let's add our warm fuzzies.
What do we get?
Yippee!
Yeah, one wish.
Give a gift.
A goods.
Ew.
Oh god.
Oh, we can only give a soccer ball.
Add the soccer ball.
Treasures are kind of mixed with the goods.
Okay, okay.
Soccer ball!
Looks like you got the hang of using the wishing fountain.
As said, you've earned the maximum amount of warm fuzzies
and money in the demo version of the game.
Since you can't get any more warm fuzzies, you've granted as
many wishes as possible in the demo version.
Hi, guy!
Hi!
Oops, no I pressed Y though.
I pressed it first.
Oh, what's going on here?
Frogbert?!
Gengar, why aren't you doing anything?
Gengar!
I have- I- oh, Frogbert fell and he can't get up!
I have to help him!
Oh, I got you, I got you buddy.
Oh.
I got you.
Are you okay?
Oh, this is a funky song.
What is this BGM?
You really helped me out.
Yay!
I'm going to give it to him the elastic.
Wait, come here.
Huh?
Something on your mind.
Oh, wrong one.
This one.
You're going to get a weak looking elastic rope!
You wanna?
I gave it to him.
And...
He likes it.
Gengar is so cute and the background is waving so much!
Let's go see what he is, what he's doing.
Yes?
Hmm.
It's your turn to spin the wheels of fate.
coin spin with me coin spin okay let's play guess which side
the coin will land on when it stops spinning if your guess
is correct you win what do you think it'll be heads or tails
heads always bet on heads huh well let's see if you're right
what's the tails though what's it look like oh
It's HETS.
You win.
Big boss.
Yay!
That's a wrap.
What did I get?
Congratulations.
You won.
Time for your prize.
Go ahead.
Pick one.
We'll go the middle.
We'll go.
I could have gotten a hedgehog!
Wait, I got a dating sim.
Why?
Who said that?
My knees are shaking?
I don't think he likes the rope you got his.
I don't think he likes the rope.
Are you okay?
Do you need me?
Are you alright?
It almost doesn't matter what it is.
Anytime I see something new and shiny, I want it.
The rope is haunting him.
Why was he saying that?
Oh, ah.
Is he going to go?
Oh, my God, he's back to it.
What's happening to him?
Oh, he's fine, though.
Kind of scary.
What's wrong?
Gengar, what's wrong?
What's wrong, buddy?
Um.
Good evening.
I can't buy the clothes yet, no.
I feel like I should have my fashion game.
Now that I've got some neighbors here on Yeh.
Get strungerone.
Welcome back away, Tome Insiderone.
Tome Insiderone.
It would be odd if everyone wore the same thing all the
time, wouldn't it?
Oh, here it is.
Okay, we're not going to go to the store quite yet because I
don't want the demo to end.
I want to see other things first.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking.
news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
At long last, yay.
Get strong, Jerome.
Welcome back away toment Siderone.
Has its very own clothing shop.
Residents are overjoyed, gathering outside the where and
where to exclaim.
So this is where pay.
I'm clicking the bubble courses, Unicam.
Oh, it's already over.
No shoes.
No service.
No!
Thanks for watching.
We saw so little.
And you're up to date.
No!
Let's see if we can find something snazzy.
Ah.
Oh, there's a cardboard box.
Yay!
The cardboard box!
I need that one.
What was I getting?
The avocado soup.
for him.
He's playing hopscotch, but there's nothing here.
He's just doing it all on his own.
Look how cute he is.
He's filled with such whimsy.
Oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, I won't let me do anything else.
He's still scared of this.
It's his training routine.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, sorry.
No!
Wait, how do I reload?
My fashion game now that I've got some neighbors here on
Yeh.
Get strungerone.
Welcome back away, Toma Insider.
I was pondering.
Did it?
Did it close the game?
Wait, but without saving.
Did it save before?
Doesn't auto save off?
You may lose a little bit of progress but not frog brain.
Okay, that's okay.
Hold on.
Just give me a second.
Let me close it.
Closing software.
Yes.
I couldn't remember which account I had to use a different
account to get the game.
I couldn't remember which account I used.
But I think this was the right one.
My name is Bob Berger from Bob's Berger.
My burger of the day is called Minteresting Mozzarella
Chocolate Burger.
Okay, okay, we're back.
We're so back.
Okay, let's have some interactions.
Come here.
Good evening.
Okay, we're not going to give him the...
Wait, not this one.
The...
We're not going to give him the elastic rope because I think
he is frightened by it.
Oh, Gengar wants to play a game, though.
Wait, can I grab you?
Come here.
Meet up.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Frogbert.
Hello there.
Frogbert, I'm known as Snake.
Known as Snake.
Their acquaintances!
Frogbert is offering a greeting with a sleepy ID on.
That's a pop album on its server.
Something about a pop album?
Oh, are they friends?
They seem like minded!
That's a terrifying thought.
I'm not gonna lie.
Gengar!
What do you want?
Um.
Let's play coins bin together.
Okay.
I got it I got it again wait I lost my I lost my what do you
think it'll be my dating sims or tails no heads heads huh
well let's see if you're right why do you seem so doubtful
it's a 50-50 chance
tails he's gonna too bad it's tails he's gonna give me like
a dirty sock
Hey, you can't win them all, but you can get this as a
consolation prize.
There's like a boat out there that's like...
Oh, he gave me toilet paper.
I was close enough.
I knew it.
Who's yelling?
Oh, oh!
Frogwort!
I'll bring someone this time.
Gengar!
Are you alright?
Please help me!
There's the source of her problem.
What does that sound?
Um, you might need to use a little more oof.
A little more oof.
What?
I vow to return the favor one day.
It was no trouble at all.
Oh, hey!
You might need to use a little more oof.
had a fun time with Frog Bird.
Oh, that's good.
And if I'm being honest, it's all thanks to you, Big Boss.
It is, it is.
Whoa, he's very happy about it.
Let's get some more food and see if we can discover
anybody's favorites.
So Snake had the the cookie, I think.
But we still need fried egg, apple, and nachos for Frog
Bird.
Oh, oh, don't leave.
My bad.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Yeah, Snake had the cookie.
Hello, where is everybody?
Snake?
So, Gengar is probably about to go cry about...
Wait, is Frog...
Wait, what's...
Okay, Frog Bird wouldn't trigger the...
It's got to be Gengar, right?
Okay.
She wouldn't trigger the main story, right?
Good evening.
What's your problem?
I'd like some dinner.
Oh, good timing, good timing.
Nacho.
Wait, I just bought these.
Welcome.
Did I not buy nachos?
Not bad.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
I thought I did.
I removed them.
Yum.
He's gonna love it?
What's up?
The nachos are so good!
I want... I want taco.
I want...
You know, I'm so, like, obsessed with corn tortilla taco
right now.
Exchange tickets is one of my favorite things in the world.
Yeah?
Well, I'm not gonna give you anything.
Wait, I'm gonna give you a cookie.
I'm gonna give you a cookie.
A butter cookie.
Yeah.
Yum.
I want to see what happens when they really like something,
you know.
You really liked it.
Or when they really hate something, you know.
Can I keep giving you more?
Even though you're full, can I give you an apple?
I couldn't.
I'm already stuffed.
No!
Hmm.
What about you, Snake?
Where are you?
oh nobody found the creamy corn soup i had right where'd you
hide it where are you hiding creamy corn
no way oh no he's drawing he's drawing gangar in the sand oh
my god it's true no i thought he was digging of the corn
soup.
Snick!
Well, I just drew the gaga from memory without even thinking
about it.
Now he's staring at it.
Um.
Oh, it's gone!
Oh, what do you need?
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna give you some more, uh, snacks.
You haven't had the nachos yet.
Please.
Love the nachos.
Yeah.
Oh, level up, though.
I'm going to give him the Maracas.
We're going to get a kiddomatic.
We're going to get
guys.
They all seem to have the same exact ones that they like and
dislike too.
Thank you.
Maybe because it's the demo.
I really wanted this.
Are you going to play with them?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Hey.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, come on.
Come on.
Woo.
Well.
Now.
Well, yeah, we gotta, we'll give Snake the rope.
Let's give Snake the rope then.
Good evening.
I come to bestow We also got toilet paper To bestow thee
with a weak looking elastic rope Oh you can't like drop it
on the ground anymore It was so funny before though And you
can do that Oh
he loves it He loves it Yeah it did manifest from his dream
So Dengaga and I both think meowing man Is just a bee's
knees Wait Do bees have knees?
Alaskan gaga.
Memento of his nightmare.
What a masochist.
Oh, wait.
Is he gonna shiver?
Maybe he has a different reaction.
Like, Frogbert was like saying it's kind of scary and
everything.
Oh, yeah.
See?
He loves it.
Oh, yeah.
Weak-looking elastic rope.
Yeah.
My beloved.
Yay.
This weak looking elastic rope, my beloved.
I like how he's on the back, back on the topic of meowing,
man.
So that would be, okay, Frogbear, what are you up to?
Whatcha doing, buddy?
Stargazing.
I know, it's a lovely night.
Thinking of going back to space to see your people.
Oh!
What are you doing?
What is he doing?
Is he...
I've heard rumors about buried treasures somewhere on the
island.
Oh, I thought he was gonna vandalize.
Oh, it can't be real.
The creamy corn soup.
It's legendary.
Huh?
I'm gonna give him toilet paper.
Good evening.
Hello!
Toilet paper for you!
I think he'll like it.
And...
Consensus is?
He hates it.
He's unsure if it's a good match for him.
Is it because frogs don't wipe?
Oh, man.
He hates it!
Frogs don't need it.
It's kind of fun to just watch them walk around and be
them... Oh, oh, he's gonna start like puking or something.
He's really pondering that paper.
Ponder the TP.
I'm getting a bad feeling about this.
Ah, it's probably like when you walk into a bookstore and
the smell of books makes you have to poo.
It's probably the same thing.
Where he looks at it and he's just like, man, this makes me
have to do something else.
I don't know, you know.
Where's Snakego?
Oh.
He moved locations to keep doing the mirage.
yeah you guys have never heard that before wait that's like
a common thing that people will go into bookstores and like
the smell of the books and stuff will make it so that they
feel like they have to go to the bathroom Google it I swear
I'm not making it up unless I saw it in a dream no I really
it was just me I'm not making it up at all I'm it's a
hundred percent real source I made it the heck up where is
he going where is he going I want to chat with someone
anyone all right here's your lucky day snake come here I
think he likes it now?
Ah.
Hey, Frog Bird.
For me, it's fabric and fake flowers.
Really?
Feels a little foolish, but thinks it's worthy to possibly
make a friend.
Pop album, pop album, pop album.
Yes!
Now I'm closer with Frog Bird.
Thank you.
Uh-oh.
Is it gonna be the demo like they they they that it was
Gengar and steak but because the demo like blocked it's it's
it's blocking his interaction they're sharing urban The
legends of the island!
Crunchy?
Wooo!
Oh!
Well anyway, juicy playpad!
Sure, live and gratch So, let's go!
Congaga?
Why is it looking like that?
So, you'll leave a charcoal with a grumpy
I do wonder about, like, the building aspect of the game,
you know?
Like, since you can customize your island and everything,
and...
I'm...
What's unfortunate is I feel like now the demo is kind of
reached, you know?
I feel like there's not so much else we can do.
Maybe!
I don't want to tear them apart.
They're having fun.
but everyone's getting along too well it's suspicious it's
suspicious yeah it's kind of in a terminal state let's see
if we can get anything to happen at the watering hole come
here
let's see if we can force any interactions here First
interaction!
Whoa.
Frogbird, good evening.
Snake, good evening.
You're telling jokes about a steak.
Oh my gosh, Frogbird thinks it's hilarious.
Wait, Frogbird, do you have any jokes?
Are you just gonna let Snake take all the attention?
Grumble, grumble, franches!
Grumble, franches!
I was hoping to see just a little bit more.
But I guess that's what they do for the demo is they give
you just enough where it's like, I want more, but we must
see more in the full game.
Just a bite.
Yeah, they leave you hungry.
No!
The accent is funnier than the joke.
I'd like to play more I'd like to add like Densetsu We can
add the sloppy sisters Ouch We can add just My friends And
other Other critters Yarrang A lizard We can make a hyper
realistic Bearded dragon We could just make the box, the MGS
box.
Nimmy?
I'd like to put Nimmy in.
Obviously, I want to put myself in as well.
I want, I want like a good number so that we could have lots
of interesting happenings going on.
And they'll all date each other.
Yeah, they actually will.
Can you make Ibu a dog?
No, you're going to be your own person.
What are you talking about?
You have to be your own person.
Let's finish up the demo then.
I still hope we got our cardboard box outfit then.
Um.
Good evening.
Wait, maybe...
Oh, I think I gave him everything, though, didn't I?
You asshole, you gave me toilet paper and made Frogbird
nearly throw up.
I wonder, though, if there's somebody that...
Oh my god, he's going in Saino mode over there.
Holy snake!
Snake!
I gotta check on this guy.
I don't think he's alright.
Um.
Do you need me?
Oh, he's still full.
Dang it.
Okay.
What did you draw?
No, he drew the...
Does that look like some toilet paper?
best I can do.
I think he drew the toilet paper?
What the hell?
Are you hungry?
Good evening.
No, he's not.
Dang it.
I shouldn't have fed them the nachos.
Is he gonna do it again?
Don't do it.
You're better than this.
Wait, what is he drawing now?
What is that?
I can't tell.
Oh, it's a toy.
You're better than this.
Frog bird.
I call this toilet paper of sand.
I thought he hated it.
Toilet paper of sand.
The sand paper.
Oh.
He's doing it again.
This is pathetic.
Oh.
What's happening?
Oh!
No, he's only can see his toilet paper.
Hey, that actually turned out.
It's supposed to be some toilet paper.
Oh my god.
I can't tell what's going on.
This poor guy!
He can't stop drawing toilet paper in the sand!
I cursed him Curse of toilet And Snake didn't even That's
not a bad drawing of some toilet paper Go me Go me
What are you doing being so cute?
Huh?
Frog Bird didn't even notice him This is just sad Yeah, he
didn't even notice knowledge oh what did you see what did
you see boy what'd you see
oh bless you god that was a that was a sneeze
they're just going about their little lives their little
Tomodachi life Tomodachi lives he sees liquid he's just like
why do i hate this okay let's see if they let's see if they
do I wish like one of...
It puts me at ease.
The grass.
It puts you at ease.
He's got a new fixation.
Bless you.
Oh, thank you.
Let's see, where else can I put you?
Can I put you in the bush?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
They're so bored.
Where'd he go?
He's not in the grass anymore.
Oh, there he is.
Frogbird!
Oh!
Nice moves!
Frogbird is admiring the stars.
I wish I could see them with you.
Frogbird.
Ah!
Sick job.
Gotta give my man a sombrero.
He'll be just like Ryden!
This is where Ryden... This is why he wanted to wear the
sombrero.
What about the rock?
You have anything?
Any thoughts about that?
Gross.
This thing's so dirty.
Dirty!
Not a fan of the rock.
Dwayne?
Johnson?
Not a fan of any of
them.
Hum?
You're the one that took it out.
What are you humming about?
Not even Bochi.
No!
All right, all right.
Now I think it's time to end.
I think.
I can't wait to get more...
You know, more little things.
things that like you know um i feel like i should uh like
little things that they can interact with you know all right
let's do our store but there's already so much
customizability it's it's actually insane but the game feels
exactly the same as the original tomodachi life like it's We
interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
It's new and shiny, but all the same at the same time.
Here's what's happening on our island.
At long last, yay!
Yay!
Get strung, Jerome.
Welcome back away, Tom and Sideroam.
Tom and Sideroam!
Has its very own clothing shop.
Residents are overjoyed, gathering outside the where, and
where to explain.
So this is where it comes from.
That's what we all wanted.
I can get past those no shirt, no shoes, no service signs.
This is where pants are from.
Thanks for watching.
Who said that?
I'm Gengar and you're out today.
Clothing shop!
Give me the cardboard.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Cardboard costume.
And we were gonna give...
We'll give...
I feel like Frogbert would look good in the avocado.
Who are we gonna get?
Oh, Gengar?
Let's try to find something purple.
Oh wait, I want like a mascot outfit.
Oh, we got his box and avocado.
Okay.
But there will be more.
There will be more.
We could do the dress.
It's cute.
Or we do two avocados.
I think so.
Snake, I have something to give to you.
Actually...
Oh, I can't, that's right.
It won't let me...
I have to finish the tutorial first.
Gwax.
I feel like I should up my fashion game now that I've got
some neighbors here on Yee.
Get strungerone.
No way, Tome and Ciderone.
Tome and Ciderone.
No, you're gonna get avocado.
It looks great!
That was a hit.
Not a level up.
Oh my god.
You're gonna get...
The true island pronunciation gets me every time.
It's best stuff because it's cut in half.
But that's why there will be two of them.
There's two of them.
Be sure to check out the clothing shop often.
You've completed the demo!
We hope you enjoyed it.
To wrap things up, we prepared a sneak peek of some of the
events that can happen in the retail version.
Please take a look at the following three scenarios.
Which event would you like to see first?
Uh...
A sly wink?
Oh!
I'm telling you.
Frogbert, snake is happening.
Which would you like to see next?
A dream.
We already saw a dream a little bit.
That was great.
Oh.
Oh, is this the one where he's huge?
Yeah, I remember this one.
Did you want to talk?
Not terrifying in the slightest.
That leaves us with this final event.
I need a drink of water.
Whoa.
That wasn't ideal.
No, my
heart...
What?
That's it for your sneak peek of events.
Thanks for giving this demo a try.
As a bonus for playing all the way to the end, Hamster.
Hamster!
Hope it looks good on your favorite me.
As a reminder that, uh, yeah, it can be transferred.
No, we're okay right now.
You've reached the end of this demo, but you can continue
interacting with your mees.
However, you won't be able to obtain more money or warm
fuzzies.
Oh, okay, good!
I thought it was like gonna kick me out.
Wait, get me out of here?
Oh, let's just give him the box.
Oh, now he's terrified of it.
What's up with this thing, man?
Come here.
Um...
Oh, what do you need?
Come here, I'm gonna give you your greatest outburst.
fit yet oh they won't leave their homes now ah that was a
hit and they also don't get happy have you ever dreamed i've
heard that in the retail version uh residents will have all
kinds of dreams oh the retail version huh snake that's such
a strange thing to say what do you mean by that
version oh skip ad you can give different gifts to residents
when they level up fancy no they really do become ad bots oh
my god oh man oh man let's get frogbert the hamster oh what
are you doing oh i was doing what snake was doing earlier at
least he's not i was i would be worried if If he was looking
at the toilet paper, you know?
If he was looking at the toilet paper again, I'd be quite
concerned.
There you go.
You unlock the add personalities.
Boo!
Oh, it doesn't look good.
Ha.
Do you need me?
Snake looks so good in the box.
I'm not going to lie.
Oh, shut up.
Well, this was still fun.
I'm excited for the full game.
Like, what will be here?
Quick build.
Something will be there.
And here.
Oh, this is, I think, the place for rooms and stuff.
Aww.
Just a few weeks.
Can you still pick them up and make them mingle?
I don't think so.
Oh, whoops.
Take, oh yeah, well, let me take him outside.
Oh, sorry.
Oof.
Naruto running, though?
They're trapped.
You guys are trapped in your homes until two weeks.
Or however, isn't it two weeks that the game comes out?
Yay!
We did the demo.
Oh, the stream ended up being a little longer than I
expected.
I hope you guys had fun.
I had fun checking it out.
We got Frogbert, we got Snake, we got Gengar.
We'll add many more creatures and critters and fun people to
our island.
Try Princess, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I cried laughing.
Some of the accents were just too good.
Oh my goodness.
It's so funny.
I wish we got some more interactions, some more events.
I think that's my kind of, like, you know, like maybe a
sample of a favorite food or something, you know.
Something like that.
But I guess they're just saving some of the stuff for the
main game, maybe.
I'm so excited to...
I'm so excited to speak!
Thank you so much for the time!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
funny.
It was so bad.
We've seen animations for favorite foods already, so you
just have to get lucky.
No!
Wait, so it is in there.
Dang it!
Gift the bubble blower.
Wait, did it not?
Wait, did we not?
It's really hopscotch.
Poor guy.
Do you need me?
Oh, It's already in his belongings.
He's just not using it for some reason.
Before this stream, I did not understand the hype, but now I
see it.
Now all I see is potential.
That's why people were begging for a Tomodachi life sequel.
People were, people were like seriously going crazy for
hoping that a new Tomodachi life would come out.
So it's finally here.
It's finally here.
Did you know in the retail version, I'll use the bubble
blower?
Emory!
For some reason, YouTube changed the chat for me.
And my pinned...
My pinned tweet?
No, not tweet.
My pinned message?
My pinned comment is at the bottom?
And all the redirects are also on the bottom.
Is that for anyone else either?
Or is it just me?
Hi Emory!
Thank you for the raid!
Being Emory Raid, yo!
Oh, mine isn't that way.
Mine's still at the top?
A lot of streamers got it.
Yeah, mine's on the bottom.
Let's do that for me too.
It's so weird.
Oh, YouTube.
YouTube.
Ah, they're changing something.
Have you tried the demo yet, Amori, for this?
I hope you're having fun with Tomodachi Life.
I can't wait to play the demos.
Oh, yeah.
You should.
It's so customizable.
It's crazy.
YouTube with useless changes.
Oh.
YouTube not doing something that nobody asked for Mission
Impossible.
It's been weird all day too, right?
So strange.
Thank you guys so much for Tamadachi Live demo today.
I had so much fun.
And, um, yeah.
Sorry if I seemed a little low energy.
I don't know.
I'm just kind of like...
I'm gonna try and get lots of sleep tonight.
I hope you feel better soon, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
at a view count bug this morning maybe that's they were
working on this thank you guys thank you thank you thank you
have a good day have a good night have a good time we just
got wait let's see who we can raid too we just got we just
got the raid too so Mii!
Mii!
Mii Wii!
Wii.
Wii!
Me wii!
Wii wii!
Let me read it this earlier!
To her, I can't read her!
Phoebe's done with Kingdom Hearts!
Wii!
Mii!
Oh, Pia!
Wait.
Oh, she is...
Where is she is?
Pia is doing a Fifi!
50,000 subscriber karaoke party, so you can get your groove
on with PMP!
PMP of Beasties!
Wait, well, let me say PMP.
I imagine she probably has redirects on.
Yes, she does.
Okay,
so much!
Have a good day, have a good night.
Bye bye!
You
too!
Oh!
I'll be recovering quick!
Here's a bit of Switch 2 fights!
No!
Me too!
We're on all stops.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Ha ha.
I caught you.
I caught you before it changed over.